bueno en este momento tenemos un debate
en todos los países de europa sobre los
migrantes que están llegando y a veces
que pueden dar lugar a unos dramas
sociales hemos visto barcos de gente que
se estaba ahogando en el mediterráneo
entonces una europa soberana en europa
que puede decidir pero también es una
europa que va a tomar unas posiciones
comunes sobre el control de las
fronteras no olvidemos que de manuel
makoun también el principio de su
presidencia de la unión europea también
coincide con el principio de su campaña
para su propia reelección a la
presidencia de francia y que a la
derecha hay muchos candidatos que están
hablando del necesario control
migratorio así que marco no se quiso
posicionar sobre este tema y el cambio
climático también será otro tema central
de la presidencia de francia en la unión
europea su propuesta es frenar la compra
de productos que hayan surgido de la
deforestación pero cómo puede afectar
esto a américa latina y especialmente a
brasil
bueno emanuel majones un europeo
convencido y en estos momentos la
prioridad va a estar dado al mercado
interno con la unión europea así que
brasil seguramente por la mala relación
que tiene también el presidente mahmud
con jair bolsonaro puede ser seguramente
un poquito afectado mayo está en este
momento en el cual no puede tener un
discurso diferente y vamos a defender el
medio ambiente y por ende vamos a
utilizar solamente energía verde no hay
que olvidar que es un presente que es
joven y que hay ha hecho de la
transición ecológica uno de sus pilares
de su presidencia en este sentido es
bastante coherente lo que dice makoun
con lo que ha hecho durante cuatro años
en la presidencia de francia y mayo
también se refirió a áfrica y a los
balcanes sobre todo para ayudarlos para
contener la migración en este sentido
que se puede esperar de las relaciones
entre el bloque europeo y áfrica y los
balcanes
bueno el presidente ha dicho que con
áfrica tenemos una relación en francia
un poquito cansada un poquito vieja y
que es el momento de repensar esta
relación de francia con áfrica no
olvidamos que también en francia hay
muchos electores que son de origen
africano y que eso también es un
directas o digamos a este electorado
dentro de su próxima presidencia a la de
su próxima campaña a la presidencia en
cuanto a los balcanes no olvidemos que
marco se ha opuesto bastante fuerte a
países como polonia o como eslovenia que
tenían unos unas políticas contra las
mujeres en contra del aborto bastante
duras así que lo que está poniendo aquí
son unas reglas claras con las cuales él
entiende jugar en el seno de la unión
europea para hacer prevalecer un estado
social de derecho como lo ha dicho y por
último el presidente francés propuso
regular los contenidos digitales para
evitar los discursos de odio es posible
lograrlo
seguramente es un desafío muy grande
pero es el momento que la unión europea
tenga una verdadera reflexión sobre cuál
es libertad de pensamiento cuál es
libertad de
expresión y respeto a los demás no
olvidemos que francia ha tenido varios
atentados muy grave que ha marcado mucho
el presidente el de samael patxi el que
tenía que ver todo todo eso estaba
ligado con las redes sociales y con los
discursos de incitación al odio al odio
así que yo creo que marcó otra vez es
bien bien coherente lo que está
proponiendo en la presidencia de unión
europea y lo que está pasando en su
propio terreno en francia